[Music]
r-ryan everybody everybody loves and
loves the rags to riches story yes I
also like riches to rags stories like a
laugh out of really what's your favorite
one the famous Vanderbilt's of the u.s.
they squandered their family fortune and
within two or three generations
generations how much was it
it's imagine if Bill Gates kids
grandkids [ __ ] up the whole entire
fortune Wow well Bill Gates unlike
Jackie Chan and then like those uh I
think some girl was like hey like
they're at a restaurant and then the the
daughter and Bill Gates split the check
right she tipped like a hundred dollars
and he took five and though which was
like hey like why did you like ask bill
I don't know if it's true but it's like
why'd you only took me five Isis bucks
when you're the world's richest man and
he goes because I'm the world's richest
and like I became that way for a reason
if if she's spending my money
so she's just spending like that and if
I continue in like I forgot how the
whole story was like if I give her my
money she's not gonna learn how to make
it or keep it because she didn't get it
but if I teach her the steps to become
that way she will then be like wait
where is Jackie Chan tlemen Jenna the
same way where he said when he dies
she's going to give any of his kids
money Warren Buffett - yeah he's gonna
give all of it to charity and he's like
survival on your own yeah he's like if
my kid smart enough you make his own
money if he's not he would just waste
all mine also easy to say because well
imagine being a kid that grew up with
Jackie Chan luxuries Jackie Chan mansion
Jackie Chan all that [ __ ] right and all
of a sudden it's like go find your own
money that's what happened to my parents
for real yeah they grew [ __ ] rich and
nobody talked about it well that's
apparently this fall
cuz it's like these my goal is to become
successful on rich one day right but I
don't want my kids to just Bank off of
me oh you also want to teach them as
they're enjoying the nice things yeah
they're too busy working to teach them
through it's like a balance yeah after
because then otherwise it's like they're
just gonna waste so they're gonna do it
and they're also going to be spoiled
rich kids that we see all the time that
they're just using their parents wealth
you know that's true and that was my dad
alright so our story here is a rags to
his story I like that that it starts
four years ago when this little girl
named Rita Gaby Ola from a Filipino town
called
bill appeal luck bun hope I said that
right look man I don't know she was 13
years old at the time and she would go
on to become a pretty big fashion model
in the Philippines would be no fashion
model yes exactly
she was discovered in 2016 and a was it
a breakdancing competition
he has festival in luck bond the dancing
competition in May 2016 a random
Filipino photographer by the name of
Topher Quinto Burgos do Filipinos and
the tightest they honestly do Topher
Quinta Burgos huh Peter ravioli was a
town like mukbang look fine look fun but
yeah he discovers her and he was like so
attracted to her natural beauty and
posted photos of her as a homeless girl
she was because she's like a model no no
I'm not she's not homeless I'm not sure
I'm ready for reporting it wrong no she
was just a poor girl she was a beggar
girl on the streets and she had like
looks of a model but she was literally
begging for money on
and he took photos of her uploaded those
the photos and it changed her life it's
like you are it's one of those girls was
like you are too hot to be begging for
money what it's got what is wrong here
my thoughts give you like one of the
rack services where someone did
something won't worry we're just hot
yeah they're like kind of like winning
the lotto isn't it her four years I'm
like damn they hustled their [ __ ] ass
off they're like hey how'd you get such
a nice figure she's like I was hungry
how do you stay so thin it's like I had
no dude wow you're so tall and slender
you know girls would kill for that body
all right this is Rita this is not
listen I guess this is the original boat
photo the original photos she looks like
she's in elementary school she does but
she looks like every girl no no I was
just setting it looks like she's in a
playground like what's the festival it
was like it was like a lively scenario I
assume and she was begging for money
there yeah and like I guess this
photographer was like I can see through
the the dirt on your face all that I can
see past the poverty I saw something
there the potential well I got high
fashion look is also a little bit
different you know my fashion looks it's
not like your traditional or like that
girl in a bar yeah it's like our
certainly yeah look now you also kind of
look kind of homeless you know what I
mean that they're really like hype stuff
I like you looking girls but high
fashion though a lot of the women look
like alien I like that through right I
like that yeah they look like hold on
are you even human doll like like funny
bigger foreheads than normal I can't
find that I find that attractive
elongated skulls yeah
[Laughter]
okay what like big eyes that are like
slightly too far apart or like the buck
teeth with my gap in it sounds like
you're explaining the alien from
American Dad
I don't like to cry skin though do you
have pictures of her now and her yes she
has about a hundred twenty thousand
followers on Instagram this is what she
looks like now can you tilt the screen
for a little bit and make it brighter
looks like I don't know she doesn't look
like Holly come garbanzo beans you know
yeah fro well she has good features
that's not good features she wears
clothes well and I think as a fashion
model I can tell because it's not T&A
you know like TNA is completely
different meaning TNA is like tits and
ass you got to have two curves and the
face doesn't really matter model II yeah
yeah she ends up being a Calvin I guess
she's working for Calvin Klein here and
do you think she's big off her story or
now just because she also looks like
that she's getting more exposure yeah do
you think she misses trash what you know
when you're older right you're like
obviously like [ __ ] it's the noodles
isn't that good but then I'm like oh you
know back in those days those instant
noodles now is five years is nostalgia
do you think she walks by a trash can
and she's like oh you see that
half-eaten burger I miss those days when
I ate those half-eaten burgers bottom
left yeah this one though was a guy she
looks so different there why does she
look like halfway there I think I think
that's the look that they went for like
she has very angular features different
yeah but like bitten the in the original
photo when she was on the street like
like she didn't she didn't look as like
like hapa or whatever oh yeah yeah a
little more like like I guess like full
Philippine or whatever I don't know but
then like I don't know I thought it was
like like she looks like she actually
eats now I feel like yeah especially in
in Asian countries I would say because
like back then they use like skin like
what the make their skin lighter and
like all that stuff but especially for a
company like having hi they're trying to
make them look
more modernize or white or whatever and
China cousin I feel like two other
people would want to become like that
well they're trying to put out an image
like white people do you know I mean
true yeah that's for sure
even you look at like marketing in Asia
you can see a lot of like China Western
eyes the look because that's what people
want that's why even before white people
they like light-skinned yeah because
like you didn't work outside yeah yeah
that's all wine that they want they've
made their skin would [ __ ] the
powdered [ __ ] well even now they they
have like I watched like these things on
like Korea and they have like all these
I face nice Thai like make your skin
lighter yeah like I think it's just more
than just trying to look like white
orlick's they're not like yeah they're
not trying to look like Europeans
they're just they just want light
light-skinned yeah because that's what
they considered like historically like
beautiful yes yeah cuz you're a princess
cuz you didn't work outside like a
peasant yeah you know what's strange to
me so like in Asia like when they seek
talent out I feel like they generally do
look for models and actors and actresses
that have like bigger eyes more like
higher bridges for the noses higher
cheekbones and like more angular faces
but what stands out to me is the eyes
because then a lot of the models and my
actors that I see talents being scouted
out here in the States
they generally have like smaller eyes
and like like I don't know you mean no
American Asian Americans cuz they want
they want to maybe to them that's what's
more a stereotypical Asian smaller I
also feel like they cuz we're here they
can stand out a little bit above the
rest right
what rather than blending in with every
single other model but there's also
another part where like I guess counter
to where you're saying cases I've also
noticed that you know like especially
the people that are mix that are like
halfway to a lot of Asians um I can
clearly tell you're half white but then
they'll cast them as the token Asian
person because no matter how half white
they are they still look nibbling ding
ding ding ding white people like you
know for like crazy rich Asians like
standards and Yohei me or Henry Golding
like to me
clearly mixed right he's clearly mixed
but then I guess to the rest of
Hollywood to America they just see like
a rice hat boy I mean you think about
that in like all the other ethnicities
right no matter how like mix they are
and if they were like a little bit black
you're like yeah that guy's just
straight-up black right you mean Obama's
half white
but yes considered a black president
yeah no yeah but people really don't
even look at him they're like oh that's
the mix president they're like no that's
the black president nothing else to him
yeah that's true I mean we define race
in such a weird way here in the states -
oh yeah Asia I think just they have a
different Beauty standard though that's
why they choose their actors and
actresses to look a certain way for
example like Asian male actors in
Western countries like they have more I
would say like masculine futures in the
Western sense yeah bigger muscular like
more like just toned all over right and
then in Asia it's it's it's that's
considered like oh you're an old guy
because it's like it's - what's the word
like they like boyish features even if
you're like really pop star yeah like
that's because the idea of beauty is
younger hmm
because out here they would say like oh
I would say like women are more
sexualized in a way that it's it's like
Oh atletic and also you know curvy and
whatever right but then in Asia
it's not the same but they're starting
to change because of the whole kpop and
globalization here I feel like that's
starting to change because if you look
at older movies even 2000s 90s the the
male person in that role it's always
like 50 maybe even 60 and then the
females like 18 yo they're always like
getting relation every wife like J Cole
James Bond movies with play Sean Connery
or like Roger Moore he's like a 40 year
old man with the [ __ ] all dude and
like you may like the current James Bond
like damn Craig when he got casted as
James Bond in like 2006 or 2005 or
whatever he did not look like the young
guy on Instagram modeling you look like
an older
right and but that was the standard it's
more extreme as you go further back you
look at like black-and-white movies with
Gene Kelly or whatever like at that
point they're like 60 bordering 70 and
then you know the girls that is the
female part is still like 18 19 years
old it's it's yeah Wow like you have
like qf yeah I feel like Western culture
and Eastern culture right now they're
kind of like it started on polarizing
ends and they're kind of meeting a
little bit they're getting closer and
closer to this medium yeah I mean Jack I
mean Jack Sparrow right what's his name
well [ __ ] Johnny Depp I mean he was like
the boy dream boy but like I don't know
like kind of kpop looking true that's
but then he hit his peak in the early
2000s when he was a little older too
I feel like with playing Jack Sparrow
several peaks I don't know I sure you
think it's like he's the kind of guy
that peaks and then destroys his career
and it comes back and he purposely
became Edward Scissorhands because he
was to like yet the girls are finding
dyslexia music I need a pic at all but
people still loved him what pick an ugly
roller girl aren't you supposed to be
taking serious man yeah I don't serious
bro just uh make yourself ugly think no
matter what he does there's like I'll be
this drunk [ __ ] pirate and they still
love us it's like why are you still cute
Accu alcoholic yeah
flamboyant fire - it's still sexy the
girls alright bye
[Music]
[Music]